awesome going for the maximum Bachelor
Grove approach of snacking up through
the game
getting started 20 23. but here we go
Robert was also correct with his
prediction of the Catalan
so we need to off our game Teamwork
Makes a dreamer
what are we seeing on the board you guys
so this is one of the main lines of the
Catalan opening this is uh played by a
bunch of top players in the world
seemingly everyone has it in their
repertoire right now white tries to
occupy some of the center but black is
Rock Solid look at Black's Pawn
structure in the middle um it's what we
call the triangle uh Pawn set up just
controlling lots of squares black does
have one problem piece in these
positions it is that black Bishop the
light Square Bishop on C8 tends to
struggle to get out it's often a battle
the middle game that we will about be
about to see of whether black can
activate that piece and this is still
very well trodden uh this path I guess
the idea behind uh this one Tanya is to
free up the square on D2 for the White
Knight but there we go we see on the
live board he has played it getting
ready to park the Knight on D2 which is
actually its dream square and uh after
black castles I'm I would be shocked
again if Magnus doesn't go for that but
uh now Knight bd2 would support a pawn
push
and uh looks like on my board we've seen
something really creative from Magnus it
hasn't popped up just yet but uh this
would be what I would go for if I were
white Let's uh go back to the players
and what has Magnus got up his sleeve
well you said creative so I'm guessing
it's Harry the H Pawn yeah that must be
it and it comes from the school of
Daniel dubarb dubov was one of the
trainers from Magnus Carlson during his
world championship matches and dubov is
kind of the king of the Catalan he loves
this opening he plays it with great
effect so they have H2 to H4 throwing
that pawn up the board it doesn't have
an immediate threat but it just can be a
bit scary for black to deal with I don't
see it yeah there you go uh Roberts he's
definitely been hanging out with Daniel
dubov a bit too much recently Magnus
Carlsen uh the white king now has the
question to answer long term does it
Castle short does it Castle on the king
side now that you've started pushing
pawns on that flank or do you just stay
in the center keep your opponent
guessing and that's something that Kai
has mentioned in the past especially
last season on the tour it's a definite
Trend at the top level to keep your
opponents guessing to kind of play a bit
risky and you definitely have to watch
out for that this is ambitious play by
Magnus and we see Serana go for the
option of B6 still keeping flexibility
in the center at some point I am
expecting a pontree to try and open up
some files your opponent goes for the
flank attack you try to open on the
center try that on Castle King put
pressure on that and as the pieces
develop I think the way for black hair
David is often to just take out the top
of the bishop on CA get it to B7 trade
the pawn on C4 pick that pawn up put
your knight on D5 and try to create play
in the center as long as White's king is
not castled yeah so this uh looks like
it's a very logical plan instead Serana
has developed his bishop and uh okay
we're waiting for Magnus to move now
something I like to point out is that
Knight on D7 right from the queen it's
dominated by The Pawn on D4 so when
there's a pawn three squares away from a
knight the Knight is in some trouble so
I do like the Contours of the position
for white because that black knight is a
bit passive so playing with E4 it's a
very common it's a top topical idea but
you offer some trades and that's usually
good for the side with less space than
Knight on D7 the Knight F6 fighting for
the same squares called Superfluous
Knights thanks to Jeremy Silman so I do
think we'll see a series of trades in
the 997 will become a happier piece yeah
finally the knights can start to breathe
but instead of capturing this Pawn Magna
says no I'm going for the attack he
brings his Knight forward of course this
Pawn will disappear long term it's now
attacked four times the white Bishop is
open towards it but uh he's also hinting
at a potential attack on this square
look how the Queen's Vision long long
x-ray vision there is potentially going
to hit the H7 pawn and Serana doesn't
even blink he's playing so quickly
against this really creative idea he
plays C5 again if your opponent attacks
one side
fight back in the center this is a brand
new position it's never happened before
so they are playing over the board this
move by Magnus going Knight to G5
attacking on e4 and now he blocks off
the center blocks off that bishop and B7
this Pawn Advance is a very typical way
of uh getting back to the position after
black has made the move C5 you want to
keep it blocked and you want to keep
pressure on e4 I like this approach of
not allowing black to capture on D4 and
opening up the center taking that pawn
on D5 and that has just happened e takes
D5 was played white has to take back
with the pawn and if we get some trades
on that square white will then castle
queenside at long last and black will be
have two pawns but white has the
initiative the momentum is the favor
there's a pin down the default the E4
Pawn will be hanging maybe there's some
better moves along the way I mean
castling King was now strong just
bringing the Rook to D1 but either way
we see how quickly White's Pieces come
into the flow of the position yeah and
just to go one or two moves further if
the black Bishop drops back we can for
example take this Pawn simply without
bishop and look at this or already
devastating threats on the board this is
a huge threat of Checkmate the black
king not entirely safe and actually I
don't really see how to prevent this it
might be the only way forward David this
threat that you pointed out of D6 and
look at the Serana chooses another part
of locating a square for the bishop
with the move Knight to H5 and the bar
hits it yeah yeah the bar hates this
move we have to try and figure out why
of course it's not just because Knights
on the rim are dim that could be one
explanation of course but it must be
something concrete something specific to
this position that makes the engine hate
this position I hate this last decision
so much by Serana I'm trying to figure
it out it feels like white has a bunch
of ways to create a double attack but no
Magnus just takes the time out and drops
this bishop back uh he's been tanking
for a while and wow Robert he goes for
the move move you suggested logical but
it does come at a cost and Magnus jumps
in instantly he doesn't hesitate to drop
his Knight on that beautiful E6 square
that is a fork you gotta move the Queen
the queen will be more valuable of the
two pieces says she runs away but here
Magnus again spoiled for choice that
white knight Is So Glorious so beautiful
do you even trade it for a rook yes you
were material but maybe you want to keep
it on that square we call it an octopus
night with its tentacles all over the
board that white knight is a real thorn
in Black side and I wouldn't be shocked
if Magnus just ignores it just Castle's
Queen site and says okay the attack
continues and you want to break that and
has he gone it does it he does it
instantly but he doesn't care about the
king safety he says I'm coming for
yorking instead G4 and I see the eval
bar loves it on the board this has
exploded already hitting that night
hitting that pawn if you capture on G4
all white ones is to take on e4 and hit
that pawn on 87 and it's really all
about the black king that Knight on E6
is way worth more than an exchange yeah
this one looks difficult what's your
philosophy Robert Tanya when you're
really struggling when you know your
opponent's almost got it in the bag but
you have to survive you have to fight
back as long as you can show up and
prevent the immediate threats he does
have a chance in this game and we see
Magnus just take this Pawn on e4 with
the bishop creating a threat against the
HM Pawn but the evaluation bar is taking
a little bit of a dip a knight can come
out to F6 there is activity for Black's
pieces and that's the best news of all
yeah and uh at least his next couple of
moves are very natural he did bring a
knight to F6 as a bit of a defensive
Rock there blacks Knights Superfluous
perhaps but they do control and defend
cover some really important squares
Magnus eventually after resisting the
Temptation for a few moves he has gone
to grab the material so white has won
that Rook for his knight uh he's
currently one point up if we do a count
but uh yeah it's more about the peace
activity white has nice centralization
black needs to just uh lock things down
and I like this last move by Serana
planting the black Bishop on D6 the dark
Square Bishop blockading white Central
Pawn you can not allow that one to
advance it would be too strong it would
win the game and he seems to have done a
good job of at least covering things for
now holding things together
do we think Magnus has a breakthrough
now or is he just going to improve his
pieces as we see in front of us David as
you were talking about the approach in
such difficult positions I think your
mindset just has to be to survive
another move you just have to make sure
that you're not losing on the spot and
keep pushing your opponent to find ways
because the hardest thing in chess is to
win a winning position we've seen even
Magnus sometimes not being able to do it
uh so that is what Serana is trying to
do he's trying to keep himself in the
game but it's going to be hard this one
because I asked him something about
Magnus he only needs a draw and Henrik
said it is very difficult to guess
and of course it is and it must be even
harder to as you say win a winning
position next really well I think that's
what sets the modern generation apart
from past years thanks to engines we've
all learned that there are resources in
positions and I do want to mention just
a couple of moves ago the experience of
these two especially in speed chess has
shown has Shone through by the fact they
both put their kings towards the corner
black took a time out to shuffle his
King into the corner Magnus even though
he's the one attacking with white took a
time out put his King on a safer square
and that's just because later you don't
want to have to calculate checks attacks
and direct threats but uh talking of
direct threats that Rook on E6 now the
white Rook has landed on a square that
the White Knight used to occupy but
still an outpost still defended by
White's past Pawn in the center and of
course by his bishop and even if black
trades off that Rook it will just be
replaced by an equally powerful Pawn
Yeah minus has so many Intruders in the
black Camp right now yeah and those
intruders are only going to start
eroding the black position further I do
wonder if Magnus can start upping the
pressure I'm not sure whether you have
time to bring your Rook uh kind of
pocket doubled Rooks there uh instead
Magnus centralizes his Knight wow nice
move and adding even more pressure onto
those two kind of most important
Defenders exchanging pieces as well as
Robert mentioned helping uh when you're
ahead on material getting off to a fast
start earlier Serana shaking his head
he's normally ice cold emotionless and
uh Fearless but Serana shaking his head
there he has played Bishop to F4 trying
to trade off these Pieces perhaps these
Bishops will that help him this Pawn has
also been freed up to start advancing in
the near future not right now perhaps
but some calculation to be done Magnus
yeah some big developments potentially
in that game and of course we've seen
the bar all up on White's favor in this
game too for a long time now and Tanya
predicted the future yet again and a
capture of Black's Defender that Knight
on F6
and it is replaced but that night the
second night will also disappear any
second now
and what's interesting is that I don't
remember these two teenagers playing
against each other so this thing could
be the first time this matchup is
happening but uh meanwhile Magnus
planting that White Queen in the center
Black's Bishop is plugging all the holes
uh that dark Square Bishop now for black
but it could be removed at any moment
first Magnus gobbles up a pawn he's
getting ready to throw the white F Pawn
forward to destabilize that black Bishop
in the center and
this one looks like we're coasting now
towards victory for Magnus Carlson uh
it's looking hopeless also down under
two minutes uh for Serana what does he
play he pushes a pawn forward this
doesn't change anything however he's
looking for counter play he's pushing
pawns towards towards the white king but
she's so far away he needs three or four
moves to create a single threat and uh
Magnus will land a punch before that to
the seventh rank so let's say you stop
with the move Queen H5 it's on the board
you're threatening a mate in one and
Serana has to defend that with the queen
losing control of the D6 Square after
which uh let's say queen goes to G7
defending the mate on eight seven and a
move like D6 would be absolutely
devastating coming in with the Rook on
the seventh Rank and this is Checkmate
incoming uh Serrano's down to a minute
and a half and the clock is not even his
biggest problem yeah we saw it in the
camera a minute ago he was just rubbing
his eyes he's like what happened this
has just been a powerful display by
Magnuson sometimes happens against the
top guys in the world yeah he was an
unfamiliar position and Magnus was not
on the attack Serana felt uncomfortable
he brought his Knight to the rim and it
never quite got back in the game except
when it was traded off the board in a
winning position for Magnus Carlson so
this is dominance this is the world
number one player for over the last
decade he's showing his force in game
one and he's about to lead one nil I
think resignation and coming yep I think
we have the results Magnus did get his
route to the seventh Frank and Serana
has resigned wow 32 moves and it's over
at Magnus Carlson he takes the first
punch the first point in the
quarterfinal match against Alexa Serana